[Musik]
es ist kein großes Geheimnis dass Japan
Probleme hat eine ganze Reihe von
Problemen aber eines von ihnen sticht
ganz besonders hervor die tiefgreifende
demografische Krise die das Land als
eins der ersten entwickelten Länder
durchlebt Japans Bevölkerung scheint
dazu verdammt zu sein unaufhaltsam und
rapide zusammenzuschrumpfen darüber
haben wir schon vor einiger Zeit hier
auf visualpolitik gesprochen und ich
werde euch das Video verlinken Japans
ölkerung sinkt um fast 800 000 zum
ersten Mal in jeder Präfektur obwohl die
Zahl der ausländischen Einwohner in den
letzten 14 Jahren um 10% gestiegen ist
ist die japanische Bevölkerung im
gleichen Zeitraum jedes Jahr gesunken
Schätzungen gehen sogar davon aus dass
Japan in den nächsten 40 Jahren fast 40
Millionen Einwohner verlieren wird das
heißt im Durchschnitt 1 Million Menschen
pro Jahr und natürlich wird die
Bevölkerung in dieser Zeit auch immer
älter werden und einige von euch fragen
sich jetzt vielleicht aber Mark was um
Himmels willllen hat das alles mit dem
Titel die dieses Videos zu tun wollten
wir nicht über das Militär die
japanischen selbstverteidigungskräfte
sprechen nun ihr müsst verstehen die
Realität ist dass diese demografische
Krise alle Bereiche betrifft Wirtschaft
Politik und ja auch das Militär einigen
Analysten zufolge könnte der
Bevölkerungsrückgang der sowohl in Asien
als auch in weiten Teilen der
entwickelten Welt eintreten wird zu
einer Situation des erzwungenen Friedens
führen dieses Phänomen wird von manchen
als geriatrischer Frieden bezeichnet
nach Ansicht dieser Experten wir die
Alterung der Bevölkerung einen neue
geopolitische Stabilität schaffen zumal
sowohl China als auch Russland mit
ernsten demografischen Problemen zu
kämpfen
haben diese Theorie besagt dass wenn
weniger junge Menschen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung stehen diese
unbedingt in der produktiven Wirtschaft
gehalten werden um das Sozialsystem
nicht zusammenbrechen zu lassen vergesst
nicht dass bei einer sehr alten
Bevölkerung die Gesundheits- und
Pflegekosten in die Höhe schießen und
das muss von jemandem getragen werden
und genau aus diesem Grund so die
Theorie werden weniger junge Menschen zu
Z Verfügung stehen und auch bereit sein
zu den Streitkräften zu gehen oder
Militärdienst zu leisten infolgedessen
würden die Länder weniger aggressiv
handeln und sich stattdessen für
diplomatische Problemlösungen
entscheiden aber ergibt das alles
wirklich einen Sinn nun vielleicht ist
diese Theorie an einigen Stellen war
aber es tut mir leid abgesehen davon
können wir sie so nicht mittragen und in
Japan das den höchsten Prozentsatz an
alten Menschen hat die also etwas
überall das wissen müssten scheint man
diese Theorie nicht viel glaub zu
schenken wollt ihr wissen warum dann
passt gut auf denn wir verraten euch wie
Japans Verteidigungskräfte in einer Zeit
verstärkt werden soll in der viel
weniger menschliches Personal zur
Verfügung stehen wird wir sprechen heute
von Japans technoarmee zuvor muss ich
euch aber noch unseren neuen Sponsor
vorstellen bei dem es im Gegensatz zu
Japans Armee sehr menschlich zugeht
italky ist nämlich eine ganz besondere
online Lernplattform auf der einem echte
Sprachlehrer aus Fleisch und Blut in
optimal auf die eigenen Bedürfnisse und
Vorlieben zugeschnittenen Stund
mehr als 150 Sprachen beibringen können
ganz easy per videall auf deinem
Computer oder Handy man kann sich dabei
für ein professionellen Lehrer
entscheiden der individuell auf ein
zugeschnittene strukturierte Lehrpläne
erstellt oder für einen Tutor aus der
Community um freie Konversation zu üben
oder auch beides ganz flexibel
miteinander kombinieren die große Stärke
von italky ist eben die riesige Auswahl
an Muttersprachlern und Lehrern aus
aller Welt so kann man anhand der
Bewertungen durch andere Sprachschüler
und natürlich in Probestunden ganz
einfache rausfinden wer perfekt zu einem
selbst passt dies garantiert einem
höchste Motivation und man holt das
Beste aus einer kostbaren Zeit heraus
ich habe mich z.B für Pedro entschieden
um me Spanisch aufzupolieren was sind
deine Interessen ja z.B Politik ich ma
sogar einen YouTube-Kanal über Politik
ja heißt visualpitik kennst du
vielleicht ja ja ja kenne ich kenne ich
bin abonniert Sog ja ja einfach wir
werden das Lesen also ich werde
das
und in in Spanien the the nicht the
sondern wie fre auf Englisch
genau okay genau total richtiggesprochen
Pedro ist nämlich nicht nur ein guter
Lehrer der weiß wie man den Unterricht
didaktisch optimal gestaltet nein er ist
auch noch politisch interessiert und
obenrein ein Fan von visualpolitik wir
haben also beide ein starkes gemeinsames
Interesse und somit viel Gesprächsstoff
die perfekte Motivation für mich ohne
italky wäre es mir wohl schwer gefallen
einen besseren Sprachlehrer zu finden
der didaktische Professionalität und
mich persönlich betreffenden
Gesprächstoff miteinander verbinden kann
in den privaten Einzelstunden kann Pedro
eine individuell auf mich zugeschnittene
Methodik Arbeiten er kann so am besten
meine größten Lücken identifizieren und
sie anschließend schließen und ich kann
mich gegenüber Gruppenunterricht viel
besser fokussieren und konzentrieren
aber ich habe gegenüber rein technischen
Apps eine menschliche Bezugsperson und
damit eine soziale Motivation deswegen
bin ich B sicher dass auch Du die
Möglichkeiten und Vorteile schätzen
wirst die italky bietet egal ob du
spezifische Sprachkenntnisse für deine
Karriere brauchst die schnell auf eine
Prüfung vorbereiten musst ein
Vorstellungsgespräch auf Englisch
trainieren möchtest oder z.B schon vor
der Reise in ein anderes Land in der
Lage sein willst die Menschen dort mit
deinen Sprachkenntnissen zu beeindrucken
auf italk findest garantiert auch du die
ideale Lösung für deine individuellen
sprachlernbedürfnisse und durch den
persönlichen Bezug die beste Motivation
dran zu bleiben bis man seine Lernziele
erreicht hat und darauf kommt es doch
schließlich an oder aber das Beste ist
mit unserem Promocode Politik bekommst
du 5 € Rabatt auf die erste Probestunde
die sonst mindestens 10 € kosten würde
also Zug nicht und probiere italky jetzt
gleich völlig unverbindlich über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung unter
diesem Video aus die verdette apritendo
viel Spaß beim Lernen auf
italky weniger Mann mehr
Maschinen werf mal einen Blick auf diese
Grafik in den letzten Jahren
insbesondere seit 2017 sind die
Militärausgaben Japans im Verhältnis zum
BP keineswegs zurückgegangen sondern
haben weiter zugenommen im Jahr 2020
erreichten sie zum ersten Mal seit den
späten 1950er Jahren 1% des BIP aber das
ist nichts im Vergleich zu dem was noch
kommen wird Japans Plan ist es seine
Militärausgaben bis 2027 auf etwa 2% des
BP zu erhöhen was dem natostandard
entspricht und das ist eine Menge Geld
vergesst nicht dass Japan eine riesig
gewirtschaft hat wir sprechen
mittelfristig von 40 bis 50 Milliarden
Dollar mehr Militärausgaben pro Jahr
damit werden Japans
selbstverteidigungskräfte gemessen am
Budget die drittgrößten der Welt sein
wir sprechen von einem militärischen
Spiel das uns nicht nur zeigt dass die
demografische Alterung nicht
zwangsläufig zu einer geringeren Präsenz
der Streitkräfte führen wird sondern
sogar das Gegenteil bewirken kann und
ihr fragt euch jetzt sicher warum
eigentlich nun wenn wir nach Japan
schauen finden wir eine mögliche Antwort
der zukünftige Personalmangel in den
Streitkräften soll durch Technologie und
Maschinen ersetzt werden eine
Veränderung die mit enormen Ausgaben
verbunden ist um euch eine Vorstellung
zu geben japan will zwischen 2023 und
2027 und 321 Milliarden Dollar in seine
Streitkräfte investieren und ja das ist
eine Menge
[Musik]
Geld Japans ziel ist es wie in der
jüngsten nationalen
Verteidigungsstrategie aus dem Jahr 2022
dargelegt Streitkräfte zu schaffen die
zahlenmäßig zwar kleiner sind aber
weitaus tödlicher mit anderen Worten ein
normales Militär soll in ein Militär aus
Eliteeinheiten verwandelt werden die
exzellent ausgebildet sind sehr gut
ausgerüstet und sich auf eine hohen
technischen Niveau befinden und das
alles soll vor allem durch den Einsatz
einheimmischer Technologien erreicht
werden zu diesem Zweck will die
japanische Regierung die Ausgaben für
militärische Forschung und Entwicklung
erhöhen und gleichzeitig zivile
Forschung und Entwicklung wie nie zuvor
einbinden und das meine Lieben Zuschauer
ist ein totaler Paradigmenwechsel für
Japan okay aber warum das alles was ist
die Motivation Japans für diese
militärrevolution nun abgesehen von der
demografischen Herausforderung liegt die
Erklärung vor allem in China Japan fühlt
sich durch Chinas wachsende militärische
Fähigkeiten und den zunehmend
feindseligen Diskurs der Pekinger
Führungsspitze gegenüber den Westen
immer verwundbarer nicht nur in
militärischer sondern auch in
politischer Hinsicht es ist in der Tat
erstaunlich dass das Land der
aufgehenden Sonne obwohl es die
drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt ist
wenig internationalen Einfluss zu haben
scheint ich meine denkt mal darüber nach
ob ihr euch jemals für die Meinung os in
wichtigen internationalen Debatten
interessiert habt ganz genau da habt ihr
[Musik]
es wenn wir nämlich seine Mitgliedschaft
in der G7 streichen würden hätten wir es
mit einem Land zu tun das wirklich nur
sehr wenig Einfluss auf die
internationale Politik hat Länder wie
Deutschland oder Kanada haben mit ihren
kleineren Volkswirtschaften ein viel
größeres internationales Gewicht obwohl
Deutschlands Volkswirtschaft die Japans
ja bald sogar überholen soll aber sogar
Südkorea dass sich zu einem wichtigen
Lieferanten im Verteidigungs und im
zivilen Energiesektor entwickelt hat
steht Japan in Sachen politischer
Einfluss bereits in nichts nach und das
meine Lieben bes Politik Zuschauer ist
etwas dass die japanische Regierung
jetzt ändern will in jüngster Zeit hat
sich diese Situation mit dem Beitritt zu
Militärbündnissen wier quot gewendet
aber es braucht noch mehr und eine
wirklich fähige Armee könnte dafür
entscheidend sein sowohl für den
internationalen Einfluss als auch für
die nationale Sicherheit wie wir bereits
mehrfach erwähnt haben hat Peking in den
letzten Jahren einen sehr beschleunigten
militärischen Modernisierungsprozess
durchgefr führt die chinesischen
Streitkräfte sind immer besser
ausgerüstet einige militäranalysten
nennen sogar ein Datum an dem China
bereit wäre in Taiwan einzumarschieren
wenn es das wollte
2027 und angesichts der Erfahrungen mit
der russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
werden militärische Drohungen von
Giganten gegen kleinere und schwächere
Länder heute viel ernster genommen vor
allem im Falle Taiwans hätte eine
hypothetische chinesische Invasion
schwerwiegende Folgen für Japan nicht
nur dass die japanischen Inseln im
Südwesten dem Zugriff Pekings viel
stärker ausgesetzt wären auch die
Auswirkungen auf die japanische
Wirtschaft könnten verheerend sein
Taiwan produziert viele der Halbleiter
und einen großen Teil der
fortschrittlichsten Technologien die von
der japanischen Industrie benötigt
werden und es gibt viele japanische
Unternehmen die direkt auf der Insel
produzieren wenn diese Versorgung
unterbrochen würde könnte der Schlag für
Japan tödlich sein und natürlich dürften
wir auch Nordkorea nicht vergessen das
bereits bewiesen hat dass es in der Lage
ist jeden Teil Japans mit atomar
bestückten Raketen anzugreifen
[Musik]
aber Moment mal denn wenn Ihr gedacht
habt dass wir euch in diesem Video
einfach nur erzählen wollen dass Japan
jetzt mehr moderne Waffen kaufen will
ist die Wahrheit die dass dies erst der
Anfang
ist Japans Plan eine Armee zu schaffen
die sich völlig von dem unterscheidet
was wir heute kennen geht noch viel
weiter das japanische
Verteidigungsministerium hat vor kurzem
z.B seine Leitlinie für
verteidigungstechnologie 2023
veröffentlicht es handelt sich um
Dokument dass die Beziehungen zwischen
den Streitkräften und der
Privatwirtschaft den Universitäten und
sogar der Regierung selbst radikal
verändert was wir euch im Folgenden
erzählen wird sicher mehr als einen von
euch überraschen meine Lieben Zuschauer
Japan hat die Ambitionen eines der
innovativsten Länder der Welt im Bereich
der Verteidigung zu werden also
[Musik]
aufgepasst Streitkräfte als
Betaversion es wird euch wohl nicht
sonderlich überraschen wenn ich euch
verrate dass die japanischen
Streitkräfte nach Jahren oder gar
Jahrzehnten der Unterfinanzierung
bezüglich ihrer Fähigkeiten nun große
Probleme haben nach dem Untergang des
japanischen Kaiserreichs und dem Abwurf
der Atombomben durch die USA um die
Kapitulation des Landes im Zweiten
Weltkrieg zu erzwingen war die
japanische Gesellschaft vollkommen
traumatisiert das Land das im letzten
Jahrhundert ein militaristisches und
imperialistisches Regime war das eine
riesige Spur der Zerstörung des Todes
durch halbasien hinterließ ist heute
eines der pazifistischsten Länder der
Welt in der Tat war eine überwältigende
Mehrheit der japanischen Bevölkerung
gegen eine Erhöhung der
Verteidigungsausgaben Anfang der 2010er
Jahre befürwortete kaum ein Viertel der
Japaner eine Erhöhung der
Militärausgaben heute sind es allerdings
schon mehr als 60%. tja von Sushi bis zu
Lenkraketen der Geschmack der Japaner
hat sich in nur 10 Jahren dramatisch
verändert und der Punkt ist dass die
Regierung von Fumio kishida übrigens aus
einer Familie mit Wurzeln in Hiroshima
der pazifistischenchen und
antimilitaristischen Stadt des Landes
stammt einen sehr ungewöhnlichen Weg
eingeschlagen hat um die
haushaltserhöhungen in Form von
Ergebnissen umzusetzen nämlich die
technoarmee ihr müsst nämlich verstehen
dass sich das japanische Militär bisher
auf die Entwicklung seiner eigenen
konventionellen Waffen konzentriert wir
reden hier von Panzern Schiffen und
Kampfflugzeugen allerdings arbeitet
Japans direkteste Bedrohung nämlich
China gleichzeitig an unkonventionellen
und hochtechnologischen Waffen wie z.B
gerichteten Energiewaffen wie las
elektromagnetischen Waffen Railguns und
Drohnen aller Art die chinesische Marine
testet das stärkste jemals gebaute
spulengeschütz spulenkanonen auch
bekannt als magnetische Beschleuniger
können die Art und Weise wie Kriege
geführt werden massiv verändern und den
Weg für verheerende Angriffe auf
feindliche Ziele Ebenen China
beansprucht für sich die Entwicklung
einer elektromagnetischen Railgun
gegenüber den Rivalen USA und Japan über
einige dieser Superwaffen haben wir
bereits in einem früheren Video
gesprochen das ich euch verlinken werde
tatsache ist dass all das geparten mit
der zunehmend aggressiven Rhetorik des
chinesischen Regimes in Japanern klar
gemacht hat dass es sehr sehr gut
möglich ist dass sie der Aggression
pckings bald nicht mehr gewachsen sein
werden und zwar vor allem wenn sie nicht
schnell einen anderen Kurs einschlagen
sie wären natürlich auch nicht in der
Lage ihre Interessen in der Region zu
verteidigen sie wären z.B nicht mehr in
der Lage etwas gegen die Invasion
Taiwans zu Unternehmen ihre
abschreckungsfähigkeit wäre gleich null
die große Frage die wir uns stellen
können lautet also wie sieht die Lösung
aus die toky vor geschlagen hat nun im
Grunde genommen eine seiner größten
Stärken als Nation zu nutzen und die
Forschung und Entwicklung von neuen
Waffentypen anzustoßen aber nicht auf
die Art und Weise wie es bisher
geschehen
ist bislang teilten die
selbstverteidigungskräfte dem
Verteidigungsministerium mit welche
Fähigkeiten sie benötigen dann
untersuchte das Ministerium welche
Waffen bevorzugt werden sollen und
beauftragte private Unternehmen mit der
Entwicklung und Herstellung dieser
Waffen anschließend baute die
Verteidigungsindustrie jahrelang
Prototypen die bis zum nicht mehr
getestet und verbessert wurden bis das
endgültige Modell fertig war dieses
einsatzfähige Modell musste dann vom
Verteidigungsministerium zertifiziert
werden bevor es in Dienst gestellt
werden
konnte tatsache ist dass dieser Prozess
10 bis 20 Jahre dauern kann bevor die
Waffe einsatzbereit ist und während all
dieser Zeit entstanden auch viele neue
Technologien die im Endprodukt einfach
nicht mehr berücksichtigt wurden ein
gutes Beispiel dafür ist der Panzer type
90 eine Waffe für deren Entwicklung die
selbstverteidigungskräfte 30 Jahre
brauchten von der Anfrage bis zur
Fertigstellung der endgültigen
Konstruktion mit anderen Worten das
Ergebnis dieses Designprozesses war ein
veraltetes Produkt oder zumindest eines
das nicht mehr auf der Höhe der Zeit in
der Militärindustrie war tja unglaublich
aber wahr aber im Gegensatz zur
japanischen Automobilindustrie hat die
japanische Rüstungsindustrie scheinbar
noch nie etwas von kaisen gehört einem
kontinuierlichen iterativen
entwurfsentwicklungs und
Produktionsmodell stattdessen nutzt die
Rüstungsindustrie noch immer das
wasserfallmod jeder Schritt des
Prozesses folgt auf den nächsten oder
nächste Beginn erst wenn der vorherige
vollkommen abgeschlossen ist und genau
das will das japanische
Verteidigungsministerium jetzt endlich
abschaffen dem Wasserfallmodell soll
einf alle mal ein Ende gesetzt werden
das Problem ist dass dies einfacher
gesagt als getan ist also wie soll es
gehen nun im Grunde genommen und das mag
einige von euch überraschen und andere
vielleicht schockieren geht es darum die
Fusion von militärischer und ziviler
Forschung und Entwicklung zu fördern
zumindest wird das in der Praxis so
vorgeschlagen und ich weiß was viele von
euch jetzt denkt aber ist das nicht
etwas ähnliches wie das was China tut
nun im Wesentlichen ja aber mit nancen
wie immer steckt der Teufel im
[Musik]
Detail auf Sicht von zehn und mehr
Jahren möchte Japan das private
Unternehmen mit einer Forschungs und
Entwicklungsabteilung sowie
Universitäten mit öffentlichen
Forschungseinrichtungen und Agenturen
sowohl zivilen als auch militärischen
sowie den Verteidigungsministerium
selbstzusammenarbeiten das Ziel ist dass
die fortschrittlichsten zivilen
Technologien wie die besten drohen
künstliche Intelligenz oder Big Data
analys Software schnell zusammengeführt
und integriert werden können um
ferngesteuerte und sogar autonome Waffen
zu schaffen die Idee ist technologische
Überlegenheit zu erreichen und
gleichzeitig die Zahl der Menschen die
für militärische Operation benötigt
werden auf ein Minimum zu reduzieren mit
anderen Worten so viele Maschinen wie
möglich und so wenige Menschen wie nötig
auf dem
Schlachtfeld Japan gründet eine
forschungsagentur für
verteidigungstechnologie und treibt ein
railgunpjekt voran aber alle oben
genannten Möglichkeiten haben mindestens
ein paar Vorteile und ein ein paar
Nachteile der erste Vorteil ist dass
Japan in einem Szenario mit einer
alternden und schrumpenden Bevölkerung
seine Verteidigungsfähigkeiten aufrech
erhalten und sogar verbessern könnte was
nach der Theorie des geriatrischen
Friedens nicht für möglich gehalten
wurde der zweite Vorteil ist dass im
Falle eines Konflikts viele weniger
japanische Leben in Gefahr wären aber es
gibt natürlich auch einige Nachteile
beim ersten handelt es sich natürlich um
die Kosten die Entwicklung eines
Militärs mit diesen Fähigkeiten ist sehr
teuer und wird ein groß Teil der 321
Milliarden Dollar an Militärausgaben bis
2027 verschlingen der zweite Nachteil
könnte die Desensibilisierung und
Entmenschlichung des Krieges sein das
könnte letztlich zu mehr zivilen opf im
Konfliktfall und blutigeren Kriegen
führen mit anderen Worten ein ganz
anderes Ergebnis als erwartet aber ist
das alles realistisch ich bin mir sicher
dass viele von euch denken wow was für
ein Blockbuster denn die Japaner da
jetzt durchziehen oder denn die Wahrheit
ist dass die Richtlinien in Ermangelung
konkreter Pläne sehr ernst zu sein
scheinen und Japans Streitkräfte werden
diesen Weg in diesem und im nächsten
jahrzehn definitiv
gehen einer der wichtigsten sollen
dieser Strategie ist dass wie gesagt das
wassermodell in der Waffenentwicklung
für immer abgeschafft wird also endlich
kaisen in der Rüstung dieser neue Ansatz
sieht vor dass Waffen die von der
Verteidigungsindustrie und dem zivilen
Sektor gemeinsam entwickelt wurden
bereits im Prototypenstadium in den
selbstverteidigungskräften eingesetzt
werden die Richtlinie ist dass sie
sofort zum Einsatz kommen sobald sie
echte kampffunktion haben dann würden
die Erfahrungsberichte der Streitkräfte
genutzt werden um diese Prototypen im
Laufe der Jahre zu verbessern bis sie
ein vollfunktionsfähiges Endprodukt sind
es ist wie gesagt ein System der
kontinuierlichen Entwicklung etwas dass
die Japaner in der Automobilindustrie
eigentlich selbst erfunden haben aber
das bedeutet auch dass sie dann eine
Armee haben die sich quasi in einem
ständigen Betastadium befindet und warum
nehmen Sie das in Kauf warum haben es
die Japaner so eilig nun im Grunde
natürlich deswegen was wir bereits
gesagt haben die Japaner glauben dass
China den Rückstand in der
Militärtechnologie schnell aufholt und
dass sie alles tun müssen um ihre
abschreckungs und Kampffähigkeit zu
erhalten darüber hinaus sieht der neue
Plan vor dass alle von Japan
entwickelten neuen Waffen dem
natoostandard entsprechen müssen um die
Interoperabilität mit seinen Verbündeten
zu verbessern und den Export der neuen
Waffen zu erleichtern aber wollt ihr an
dieser Stelle vielleicht ein paar
konkrete Beispiele dafür was Japan im
Rahmen dieses neuen Plans zu bieten
hat nun abgesehen von der Verbesserung
der Railgun die bereits auf einem Schiff
getestet wurde will Japan eine Reihe
neuer unkonventioneller unbemannter und
sogar autonomer Waffen entwickeln
ultrafeste Waffen die mit 5g Arbeiten
aus tausend von Kilometer Entfernung
genutzt werden können und die sehr
geringe Latenzzeit dieser Technologie
nutzen aber es gibt noch mehr eines der
ersten Dinge die sie in Betrieb nehmen
wollen ist ein
hochleistungsmikrowellensystem dabei
handelt es sich um eine gerichtete
Energiewaffe die im Falle Japans gegen
sättigungsdrohenangriffe eingesetzt
werden soll das ist genau das was die
Ukraine gerade dagegen die russischen
chikalzitronen bräuchte außerdem sollen
vorrangig unkonventionelle Energieformen
für den Betrieb der Waffen genutzt und
neue theoretisch viel perfektere
Materialien entwickelt
werden tatsächlich verweisen die
kürzlich veröffentlichten Richtlinien
auf eine Entwicklung eines neuen
Materials das nicht nur stärker ist
sondern auch eine perfekte Mikrostruktur
hat die sich sogar selbst regenerieren
könnte aber Japans Ideen für die Zukunft
beziehen sich nicht nur auf Technologien
für Angriffswaffen sie wollen auch viele
sehr wichtige und effektive Waffen
entwickeln an die ihr vielleicht gar
nicht denkt nun japan will die besten
Systeme für die Verbreitung von
Falschinformationen schaffen ja ihr habt
richtig gehört die guten alten Fake News
aber auf einer ganz anderen
Ebene lass es mich erklären durch
künstliche Intelligenz das Metaversum
und sehr fortschrittliche
dieepfaketechologien oder sogar durch
die Projektion von stereoskopischen
Hologramm will jampa den Feind sowohl
auf dem Schlachtfeld als auch außerhalb
täuschen auf diese Weise wollen sie
Desin Information verbreiten um die
Menschen Dinge glauben zu lassen die
einfach nicht wahr sind und um sich im
Falle eines Konflikts einen Vorteil zu
verschaffen die Japaner sprechen sogar
davon Objekte so zu projizieren als
wären sie vollkommen real es geht um
Technologien die mehr oder weniger stark
im zivilen Bereich eingesetzt werden die
das japanische Militär aber so weit wie
möglich übernehmen anpassen und
verbessern will um sie zu Waffen zu
machen okay vielleicht klingt das was
wir euch gerade erzählen für viele von
euch verrückt und glaubt nicht dass ich
das nicht verstehe aber lasst mich euch
eine sagen alles worüber wir hier
berichten steht in der neuen offiziellen
werttechnischen Leitlinie Tokos also ja
das ist es was Japan im schildde führt
die Frage die große Frage die wir uns
wahrscheinlich alle Stellen ist daher
werden sie damit wirklich Erfolg haben
wird Japan bald über fotoristische ultra
vernetzte und super mechanisierte
Streitkräfte verfügen nun auf eines
könnt ihr Gift nehmen wir werden diese
Entwicklung genau beobachten und euch
davon berichten also vergesst bitte
nicht das Abo und Glöckchen um diese
Videos nicht zu verpassen und wenn euch
dies Video gefallen hat gebt ihnen doch
einen like und teilt es mit euren
Freunden damit sie auch was davon haben
macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald